all right welcome everybody to another
YouTube hangout last one of the day we
saved the best for last as playoff
season everybody I'm super excited to be
here with my new friend Daniel D Piazza
he's got a man Daniel this guy's all
over the place he's done so much man he
was a bodybuilder he's an entrepreneur
who's got a podcast he's got a blog he
wants to inspire Gen Y entrepreneurs to
go and crush their businesses and he is
joining me here today he's going to do
an interview with me for his podcast so
I'm gonna let him run the show but
Daniel first of all welcome board man
and maybe just quick intro for my
audience so they know a little bit more
about what you're all about yeah man um
and thank you for forgetting me here
behind the scenes and I love your hoodie
by the way you haven't what's the UM
what is the paper claim like the paper
plane well you want to do this on your
show you wait this is all pre-show you
do whatever paper plane is here is an
airplane taking off it's mint it's also
the gesture I always go believe continue
to believe it represents the
entrepreneurs journey at the start we've
got this idea you want to fly you want
to soar but you're like this paper
airplane taking off and like the winds
beat me down but you still you still
believe you still gonna fly so like it
represents against all odds at least for
me against the law is going out and
trying to fly high but you want to be
supersonic jet even though you realize
just a paper airplane right now you know
what that actually is my exact story
tubes that you said it right there you
know
my intro Michael do you man that's that
that's my mantra I think that all of us
have the ability to take off like the
jet like the airplane but and part of it
what I realized recently about Evan is
my job to have conversations like these
so that people can realize that there's
more possible for them um I like if we
could just be honest for a minute I do a
lot of podcast a lot of the video stuff
oh yeah you know Generation Y hustle and
all this stuff that's great of what
we're doing right now like well we talk
strategies if you want
I'll let the purpose of what we're doing
is sometimes you just need to see the
same ideas like a thousand times before
you can take action on that look at your
channel you know you based all your
content on great people who've done
amazing things and how many times you
need to hear an amazing story in order
for you to start doing your own thing
you know maybe you might need to hear it
a hundred thousand times but it's the
same it's the same as it is with me as
you so I could go on to tell my story
about how you know I quit my restaurant
job I started freelance and all this
stuff and then you know I got an
entrepreneur Time magazine now I'm going
not bragging right but but the reality
is my story is any any more interested
in anyone elses but maybe if we have
this conversation people will hear what
you have to say here would have to say
real solid [ __ ] they're just normal
people maybe I can do that too tunnel
you know I love a man I love it well
we've linked up your stuff below - so
guys after you're watching this go check
him out - he's got some quality content
much appreciated
so yeah man you know you don't if I
really interesting about you is that
you've done something that it's become a
lost art it's you know I think I don't
know bowling stop there you're certainly
carrying a torch
and it's it's the investigation of what
makes three people great there's a lot
of there's a lot of noise in the space
where people try to hijack the names of
credible people in order to boost their
own credibility
I saw one ad on Facebook I I normally
never respond to ass because they're
just ads but I saw one and I said Seth
Godin was wrong here's what you don't
want a purple cow and the rial they're
trying to do was hijack sense
credibility their offer wasn't good at
all but what you've done is you've taken
great names great stories and you've
made them compelling enough to first of
all be very highly clickable on your
stuff I want to see it but second you
actually distill meaningful takeaways
that don't get boring and overused as
you compare ten different executives so
how do you select who you who you want
to dissect and then how do you make it
different enough words continue to be
engaging so people
videos don't get bored after war - sure
and thank you for that awesome you know
word of encouragement I guess there was
those those cool man in terms of picking
the people at the start was people that
I this all started cuz I wanted more
motivation in my life right like I felt
the friends that I had we're okay and
like good people whatever but weren't
pushing me to do more I felt like I saw
the world as being a bigger place and I
wanted to have a much bigger impact than
the people around me the people weren't
just they weren't thinking big enough
and that's no like not a knock on them
just I knew that I need to go and do
something else I need to surround myself
with bigger ideas and so I thought you
know what the more time I spend
listening to Steve Jobs or Howard
Schultz or Bill Gates or Martha Stewart
or whoever these people are you know I
may never meet these people some of them
are have passed already but if I just
spend time kind of watching their stuff
a little bit of their stuff rubs off
onto me a little bit their magic dust
their mindset their you know breaking
through barriers rubs off on the me to
make me want to go and do more and I
think a lot of people they may hear one
speech you may hear like Steve Jobs is
Stanford commencement speech right like
you know every entrepreneur I think I've
seen that video and so classic and that
then you're fired up for the rest of the
day but how do you wake up the next day
and fire it up again right and as you
said a lot of times with these limiting
beliefs that we have you need to hear
the message over and over and over and
over again from different voices from
entrepreneurs from athletes musicians
and finally eventually it starts to to
break in because you've had decades of
conditioning where you know your parents
and your friends and your community
teach you to think a certain way and you
realize that you have to break out of
that but you don't know how and so
reading the new community and my
community are the people behind me the
people on my website right the people in
the YouTube channel the people done
great things I want to be around them as
much as I can so that's like why I
started doing this in terms of selecting
at the start it was people that I I just
was curious about I wanted to learn more
about
it was selfish for me we've now grown to
the point where at the end of every
video I ask people hey who do you guys
want to see like leave a request in the
comments and I'll see what we can do and
we take the most requested people now
and it's super interesting cuz there's
been a lot of people that one i've never
heard of before
now I've like learned some awesome
lessons especially non-north American
entrepreneur gosh man like oh my mind
and if you're a fan of the channel
you've seen them and also people that I
didn't expect to have a great message
I remember Selena Gomez I remember
Denzel Washington and like not a knock
against them as people but I was just
like wow man Denzel dude he's got some
awesome it's sick and I just I knew the
guy's an actor but I didn't expect him
to like inspire me with his words so you
know a lot of people who we may judge or
like I could I want to be learn from
anybody who's had success not just from
an entrepreneur but musicians and
athletes like that that success trail
these clues that you can learn from so
that's where it comes from in terms of
how do i how do i pick like the right
lessons it's really just what inspires
me
you know like we'll sit down and I'll
watch you'll go through like 20 hours 10
hours Elon Musk footage depends on
what's out there to take like 15 minutes
that's his best stuff that he's ever
said and it's really like the best stuff
it's just what I like it's like I
watched it and you watch an hour-long
interview and he says one thing that
resonates with you you know maybe I
missed some stuff but that's what hit me
and so I just share the things that hit
me and bring them all together and then
share with you guys and thankfully it's
been accepted right it's like you guys
like it - everybody's getting inspired
so it's really just the lens through it
you know I see the world and I'm really
grateful and thankful that other people
are kind of hopping on board too you
know I mean you know part losers
overlooked
overlooked element of Education which is
not just outright teaching of concepts
but also connecting students with other
great minds so that they can further
their own education you know it
certainly is useful to help bring
someone to a realization after having an
expose them to new ideas and I think
that the ear role as a curator under
role as a distiller of information is
just as important as let's say you know
you were actually working on some of the
projects all the people that you that's
you kind of you know connect yourself
with um this is for me what I see to be
the difference between kind of just
information and insight there are a lot
of people giving up information out
there insight though is distilled
knowledge that has some sort of meaning
attached to it and I'm just curious you
know over the past I guess how many
years have you been have you been doing
this for now I've had the channel for
six or seven years this wasn't always
the the incarnation of it it's kind of
known I think it more seriously if you
think about the my real traction started
coming when I made daily videos and the
top tens and the lessons so maybe maybe
two years of doing that hmm yeah that's
the first I mean I know she was probably
where a lot of people did with the Steve
Jobs video that kind of blew up I was
about a year ago and I've seen you know
that you know you must go back and watch
all the rests when you see one I'm
curious how has how has your like the
constant creation of content change your
life there's something I talk about with
my readers and followers of the the
virtue in an in and of itself of being
prolific you're publishing something
every day how does that change your life
I'm a big believer in that quantity
leads to quality mm-hmm and that people
often ask is a quantity or quality well
it's both right like you can't just make
one great video a month unless you're
like your
is off the charts but to get there you
have to practice just like anything else
like you want a good jump shot you got
to go to the gym and practice yeah you
want to learn a language you got to
practice and so it's the quant the
quantity of whatever you're doing helps
lead you to the quality this has been an
evolution for me so at the start I did
everything myself and I made one video a
week and in like I was doing everything
I was camera man I was script writer was
researcher I was editor you know it was
everything and I'm not good at most of
those things but I I'm a big believer in
that you gotta you gotta you gotta test
it out before just diving in and
spending tons of cash on it see if you
like it see if it falls into place for
you my big growth started coming when I
hired my first editor and we moved to
one video a day
now we've got three editors I've got a
researcher I've got an assistant so
there's like six of us who work on the
YouTube channel and part-time cameraman
who comes in once a week to film me
doing this video cuz like I make time
for I still review all the videos before
they go up I'm doing two live streams in
the morning that one on gratitude and
one on me playing League of Legends
while I answer business questions and
we're up to like we're up to five videos
six videos a day on the YouTube channel
and it's frizzy for a lot of people
they're like that's nuts
today this is my seventh video man of
like life but I've made it part of what
I do yeah this is what I love man other
people might look at this Jerry finds
Jerry Seinfeld Jerry Seinfeld calls it
the torture that you can manage the
torture that you love right like other
people look at this and say man that's
torture how could you do that for me I
love it I get energy from this man it's
like I've done 6 Daniels coming up let's
rock this man this game - game 7 that's
it man it's great I mean I love it I'm
my wife's coming home tonight we're
gonna film some videos for the channel
it's like it's non-stop but I love it
this is what fuels me and brings us
together as well and brings the
community together we got a live
audience watching right now so I think
you gotta find the thing that you can
put that kind of love equipment
- because if all I was doing was you
know what I want a million subscribers
on my youtube channel I would have given
up a long time ago too many people are
so attached to the goal that they don't
they don't enjoy the process and you
have to enjoy the process of the work
like there is no final outcome the work
is the outcome I want to do more work I
love what I'm doing I'm sure for you to
like interviewing these people and
getting knowledge into your head and
spreading that message to the next
generation if you didn't love doing it
you were to quit you know after the
third episode totally man I mean and
then you got a different about you know
you have to find the medium that allows
you to create at that prolific pace
everyone has a different way that they
like to get stuff out there I have
always been a writer I mean that's just
been the core my my thing I mean you
know from from SATs all the ways that my
growing up life that's just what I like
to do and people ask me you know how do
I manage to write so much and you know
they're flabbergasted when they you know
learn that I write on the weekends -
once you write on Saturday and Sunday
yes managers manage truck drivers
driving trucks writers write you know
youtubers YouTube you know I look at
this as really fun and exciting and
lucky that I get to do it all so
blue-collar like time to put up you know
I'm here in the morning that I'm this is
my writing time this isn't like I don't
really have beyond the mentality of this
peak you know leisure activity they get
paid for this is a very serious activity
you know of the right and so I'm totally
with you and five five six seven video
today is a crazy month that's what I
call Tupac level of production yeah I
think you probably even did a video
about you Bach we did yeah I know you
know part of the mission - is what I've
noticed is this was an unintended
consequence but I'm super grateful for
it because we've exposed ideas of people
that other people may not have heard of
before or wouldn't get the time of day
for we are putting people in a positive
light and it's having a big impact so as
an example we did a video which one of
the Johnsons is in Magic Johnson or John
Johnson I don't remember which one but
anyway one of the Johnson's and I
remember this guy wrote to me he's like
you know what I'm
from one of the southern states in my
parents always taught me that black
people were just stupid and I watch your
video of mr. Johnson and I realize that
I'm the stupid one my it's like man like
these videos are helping with racism
right like it's yeah it's crazy to think
and so Tupac you know a lot of people
see him just as a thug and a gangster
and in you know they just know him from
the news stories that came out and we
did a video on him and and everything
again is seen through the lens of what I
learned from them so sure I don't learn
the the violence and the gangster side
from Tupac but he at the same time was a
thought leader was a poet was you know a
genius and there's a lot that you can
learn from him and so people watch that
video and they're like man Tupac was you
had some good things to say so it's it's
just interesting how how people get put
in the box
and wanted like Kanye is a great example
of a hate comment they hate Kanye
Kanye's on my wall I don't even see
there at the back bunnies on a lowrider
learn the fire on the wall skinny asian
we know back yeah I know he's at the
side but if I'm in the back by the way
well let's load it back from here you
know it's the first one I see but you
know a lot of people see you and again
like what you see as him is all the
negative stuff all the tabloid stuff all
the crazy stuff and yeah maybe he does
saying the wrong things a lot of times
but he's also a genius and he's also had
a positive impact like John Legend got
his name because Kanye convinced him to
change his name to John Legend Yeah
right because he was afraid that he
wouldn't live up to the legend status in
one Stevens is it no man you gotta you
got to be bold and so and John Legend is
like the nicest guy of all time and you
would how is he friends with Kanye how
does that make any sense right but you
can see the love that he has for others
to in the impact that he wants to make
and so that's part of it is it's been
interesting
to kind of break down prejudices and be
able to see that everybody has all these
successful people have a message that
you can learn from even if you disagree
with a lot of positions they took you
can still learn from their success
that's a great point and I used to have
a tendency when I was younger to be
really irritated when I would read or
watch something that didn't agree with
you know or something that struck me as
like something struck me as like false I
wouldn't give you I wouldn't even
consider any of the context or any of
the source so let me give you an example
um one of my background I was kind of
like learning more about spirituality
and learning more about just you know
because open-minded I'll help you date
[ __ ] um I ran into OSHA I'll clean up a
boat show vez if you ever seen before he
lives long beer this oh so he's a pretty
out-there dude and he has some
interesting ways of thinking and I got
some of those books and I like some of
his ideas but then I was reading about
on Wikipedia and I learned and he had
some also some trading [ __ ] going on
yeah like this weird cult thing
happening and he was like a cute
poisoning this water or some some like
really bizarre stuff it's not that
doesn't really happen unless something
shady was going on I think I had to
leave the u.s. I don't yeah yeah okay
yeah he was he told me to leave then he
went to like he was in trouble in India
and all this stuff and it kind of like
for me to kind of tainted his lessons
cuz I'm like oh he was kind of [ __ ]
I don't think Kirsten here caption head
and maybe I shouldn't wisdom but then he
knows it took a step back we had our I
thought you know a lot of people have
different science uh Kanye has his
[ __ ] side Tupac has his [ __ ] side Oh
she'll probably has some sketchy stuff
too no one that you think is virtuous no
one that you really look up to is gonna
have all good size you might see them
through that lens you know Steve Jobs a
lot of great things but we all know if
we read his biography by Walter Isaacson
he wasn't like peach okay so so it's
important to view people honestly and
speaking to that to that note you are
kind of you're working on your book it's
coming out
today we come out by the way challenge
yourselves December 6 here's one word
yeah it comes out December 6 yes so
going to go on to get the book in it if
evidence been worth at least one hundred
seventy six dollars to you go ahead and
invest in ten copies of the book because
he deserves it in the world is you
deserve to see more that message but
you're becoming down more of a personal
brand right because you have to like
step out from outside of you know the
faces that you've been so loyally
supporting and now become your own rebus
you're the author you guys what's right
for you how has how is the role of
honesty played a part if at all again
because you're still kind of I'm having
in the suction I don't know how much of
an ever you've made to develop a
personal brand of this point but it has
the idea of being more honest as a
personal brand scared to you at all so I
went through the whole personal brand
thing when I was doing my website much
more than my youtube channel I made a
website after I sold my business my
first business and I had some of these
guys Steve Jobs and all these guys on
the site articles about their success
right that's what helped get me through
my startup and my failing and my
eventually succeeding is the stories
both for the ideas and what to do and
just the inspiration seeing how these
guys started with like less than what I
already have right now and turn in
something amazing that inspired me so I
put it off on my websites just to I
didn't want other entrepreneurs that
suffer the same way I did in your head
that I was I mean I'm sure it's part of
the reason for you to like wanting to
give back and help and have people not
suffer through the problems that you
faced and kind of learn from success in
the website was off my name and people
wanted to know who I was
okay well who cares who I am like I mean
I built the business I sold it but I'm
nothing compared to Howard Hughes and
Steve Jobs and his accomplishments I
know is only because people kept asking
what happened what's your story
the most requests to top 10 of my
channel isn't is my top 10 people want
to know what my top and is I haven't
done it my fans the one together for me
but I haven't done it my own butt so I
kinda had to go through that it was a it
was a gradual process on the website of
okay well people want to hear about me
so I'll share a little bit and then and
then as I shared people wanted to know
more so shared a little bit more by the
time I hit my youtube channel there was
already a lot of me answering questions
and being a part of it I think it's just
blown up more now so other people are
finding out about it the content on the
channel
the easy point in is the top ten rules
where I'm barely and I just introduce
the person and I can include it the
other series there's a mix of me in
another entrepreneur and their others
that are just me so you you ease your
way in if you don't like my message you
know you could just stick with the
famous entrepreneur's you want to you
want to go deeper and learn more about
what I'm doing that's awesome I don't
expect people to watch every video you
know like making seven videos a day on
the channel I don't expect everybody but
I also don't limit myself a lot of
people say well why don't you do one one
a weekly these other guys I'm a channel
man I'm not a show I'm a channel I'm a
channel right I want more cons I want
you to be able to Ninh there's always
something inspiring for you to be able
to do I don't CNN doesn't need you to
watch every single show they put on Fox
you need to watch every show you put on
so I don't know I think people have a
limited mindset around that but yeah I
got used to it on the website side by
the time I hit youtuber was already
sharing some of my personal first salsa
it was hard though it was a journey it's
more like well Who am I compared to
these people but understanding the
person behind it and their motivations
and their thought process actually helps
you tell the story better it helps them
connect to the famous people better as
well yeah that's a good point I mean
because there's there's so much of this
aura of like specialness around these
famous people but a lot of times they're
kind of summing the dark hitting their
heads too and you don't realize that
until you see how it relates to your
everyday life when you were growing your
channel I don't know this is this is
hyper relevant for me because you're in
Toronto right yeah
okay I'm in LA and and we have
billboards of YouTube celebrities all
over the all over
Canadians Lily sings Canadian yeah
Lily's think is amazing she's amazing
huge fan and it's crazy that you can
pretty much create this machine for
yourself now and jump in it and then you
know you can I mean I went onto the
YouTube space in LA here and it's
incredible that they built an entire
studio for people to use and its purpose
essentially free the only condition is
just create really good content yeah me
we're not if you're if you don't get
what's going on here you're completely
out of your [ __ ] mind like I see
their YouTube plaque on the side right
they're like this is in there there's so
much there's so much potential here did
were you jealous are you intimidated
when you're trying to grow your channel
and seeing other people or having
success one is you could do the same now
man because it's never been about the
YouTube like as much as I want to hit a
million subscribers or whatever when I
first started it was never about that it
was just trying to share it was an
honest attempt to share the stories that
inspired me in my business and I hope
just from I was making 300 bucks a month
man like I was struggling when I was
doing my first business and and I just
really didn't want other people to have
to go through that and so I thought hey
you know what these stories motivated me
I'm much more of a visual learner than
than reading so I thought hey if I could
make these into videos tell the stories
of some of these entrepreneurs like the
things that I wish that I had when I was
starting my company then maybe that'll
help inspire some other some other
entrepreneurs and help them not you know
fall into some of the pitfalls that I
did because I almost quit too and I
almost went back to get in the job and
man that would have been a big mistake
so my goal is always like it's always
the work I'm what motivates me is the
community that people watching now the
people leaving comments every day I want
to have an impact I want to reach a
billion entrepreneurs you know the the
growth numbers are great but it's much
more about the process so I I'm not you
know I'm not jealous of anybody in the
in the in the YouTube space if anything
I'm a little sad that there aren't very
many like it
good educational content channels like
for at more of a release or an escape
than to to learn but you're like you
can't complain you just gotta turn up
the dial and be the change man now I
want to see that I got a little make
better videos I got to make my mark so
there's always been some like fun
competitions I haven't made yet I'm
sorry I have an agent a business agent
who like books Beyond deals and stuff
and when I first joined there was
another guy at the you can see who had a
bigger channel than mine and so it's a
long about I'm gonna be that guy but
more like friendly competition than
anything else like I'm not gonna go and
step making stupid cat videos or just
just do stuff and that's part of like
the process with the book right like the
book helps you identify what it is that
you really stand for and then now you
start to live a life and run a business
on purpose instead of just reacting you
know an older FS are a younger version
of me might have just been focused on
the goal of hitting the million
subscribers whatever has to take to hit
that million subscribers or whatever you
know goal you're chasing without it
actually been the meaningful work that
you're doing being important so once you
know once you're on a mission you just
you just continue man like if I hit a
million is awesome
I'll keep driving I'll keep driving like
this is the stuff that makes me come
alive so even if I like even if I was
making $0 I would still do this because
I would have to find another way to
survive but I love it right like that's
that's when you know you love something
and I'm sure you're the same way man
just you find the thing that you love to
do you got to find a way to keep going
even if you're not getting paid and this
is a great disagree quarter I was just
talking about this I fly mothers on
snapchat yesterday I should make a video
about this the idea that the idea that
you should have some things in your life
that are pure passion projects and not
everything there's there's this big this
is going to be hiked up a little bit
there's this big comples with fog now
around the idea that you know you should
find your passion and get paid for it
you have to get paid to do is love and I
slightly disagree with that because I
feel like
it's you should do what you love no
matter what and getting paid for it
would be a bonus but it wouldn't be the
goal like perfect example with you the
videos you said you'd do them no matter
what and you love them so you'd do them
getting paid for the ballot bonus but if
you didn't you'd work it on the job and
you still do the videos because the
videos are important to you you know we
all need to have something in our lives
that's so important that it is not
influenced by the desire to make money
because if you're influenced by desire
to make money you're always or in most
cases going to make some changes and
sacrifices to adjust the amount of money
you're making you know for me that
irreplaceable think I mean writing is
one of them of course but now I'm out
into that space where I'll I'll stood a
pager right so obviously I'll think
about things that might do well and I
will read those things sometimes but for
me something is purely on attached to
money is jiu-jitsu how did you do to
everyday I'm not gonna be a I'm not
gonna be I might one day instruct it but
it wouldn't be as my career I'm not
gonna be a like a legendary jujitsu
fighter I might win some tournaments but
I'm not trying to be a well I actually I
heard that she would love to be a world
champ but that's outside that wouldn't
be for money it would just be as a
result of the fact I love it and that
gives me such a fulfilment that I
understand now helps me to reconnect
with what the purposes of the work that
we do I have people who will now watch
my videos and say this video made me
interested in jiu-jitsu now my trying it
and I know how it's going to affect that
person's life and that's gonna affect
maybe their kids their grandkids all
this stuff because you can you can
offense even as scale a lot of people by
touching one person this one person said
to you I'm not here basically I'm not
racist anymore because your video how
many people is that gonna affect he's
gonna have kids and grandkids they're
gonna have use now that are a result
that this guy saw in your videos and a
light ball turned out like holy [ __ ]
black people aren't dumb it's a big deal
you know so now if you were saying I'm
gonna wait till I find I can get paid
with and I'm also passionate about to do
them and you might have made that video
and then that guy wouldn't have that
insight so it's important to do what you
love
even if you aren't gonna pay for it at
first yeah I knew you liked most of the
time I'd even say most of the time
the thing that you love to do because
it's a matter of the heart there is no
logical thing there is no logical path
for it yet like when I started doing
this I I did present my first entry to
helping entrepreneurs was I did a thing
with the YMCA my local YMCA to help out
they said can you come talk to our group
of entrepreneurs I just sold my business
sure I'm happy to come and I promoted it
and they promoted it was this free thing
and three people showed up to it I'm
gonna do the man like this is huge room
full of chairs under people and three
like first of all my I just felt super
embarrassed that yeah it didn't work but
also how am I ever make this a business
right how am I gonna make this a
business three people show up to a free
thing how am I ever gonna get paid to do
this but you know I showed up I talked
to those three people it was amazing and
I'm like you know I don't care I have to
I have to volunteer I don't know I've
got to find a way to keep doing this and
it's that love and dedication that then
you figure out a way to make it super
valuable so then you end up getting paid
for it I recently acquired salsa dancing
school here in Toronto
probably the largest in North America
teaching people how to dance salsa
classes and when I first walked into a
salsa school you know a practical level
I'm too tall I don't speak Spanish I
don't understand the music at that time
I take big steps and are we still there
okay I take big steps and like
everything is against me on paper to be
successful here and if I went in with
that mindset okay I have to find my next
business opportunity it's gonna come in
this first class or I'm out right or
like you go on a date with somebody but
I'm gonna get married or or that's it
I'm out you know you got to experiment
you gotta you gotta test and see what
happens right and and by not having that
expectation of making in the business I
found out that I loved it and it became
a business that I invested in and then
acquired and so I think to though when
you find something that you love you
have a
duty to also share it so like for you
with jiu-jitsu I'm sure I mean I haven't
seen your snap so I'm sure you probably
also like snapping up you know in the
change room where your competitions or
whatever
definitely so like even if you never but
but then so like that leads to you
building your brand like you're making
money off of it right even though the
execution of making money may not be the
traditional one up I'm going to be
jujitsu instructor well I'm gonna launch
a YouTube channel around Judas soo or
I'm gonna sell DVDs or infomercials or
whatever like maybe that's not the path
but you could still make money off of
jiu-jitsu you just haven't found maybe
the plan yet but you're kind of already
are in bringing it up on your podcast
and using it to connect with people and
bring it up on your snapchat and that
helps you build everything else that
you're you're going with so you never
know how it's gonna play out and it
often like almost always never plays out
like the way you think is going to and
the only thing that keeps you going
through all the uncertainty all the crap
all the clouds all the mess is just the
drive the love the love of the work the
love of you did said the love doing
these interviews
I'm just not caring like even if it
doesn't work out I'm still gonna keep
doing this because I love it and
eventually what so that's I mean this
looks - that's that that's one thing
that that one of my you know most
esteemed I suppose thought leaders often
talks about this that's going in you
know he's always talking about trying
things even if they don't work because
the virtue is in to try and think that
virtue is in starting and I think this
is something that is becoming washed
over a lot with with our culture now
because social media has really focused
the camera on the results especially
with you know Instagram snapchat you
know all the type of stuff where we're
very focused on luxury and I almost
think that luxury is becoming itself the
intangible concept of luxury is becoming
something that we're reaching for but
not really know we're reaching for we
just see you know really well cropped
photos great filters we see expensive
things and nice trips to good meals we
think okay
I want to get that and then I got to do
something to get from where I am to that
and so maybe I'll just try this internet
stuff do you think that there's gonna be
a point where entrepreneurship or really
kind of where we are in terms of like
entrepreneurship as a as a as a craze is
it going to die down are we kind of like
at a point where Cinderella is turning
her carriage turned back into a pumpkin
at midnight in Oxford your trips not
gonna be cool I feel like whoa first uh
I mean we might be in a bubble but I
don't think it's gonna go anywhere
either man I think it's only gonna get
well I like get worse but I feel like
that's getting better I feel like as
people see role models and people see
the opportunity to do things like people
see Zuckerberg and say man look what he
did I want to go do something I don't
want to work at this crappy ass job
right I want to go and chase my thing
and go do my dreams right I think as
people understand that the opportunities
as the barriers are coming down they're
gonna jump on it and there's just going
to be more room I think more people are
just going to do their own thing I think
I think the the people in danger are the
ones who need somebody to work for them
for 40 years at a nine-to-five job I
don't think that's gonna happen anymore
so whether you know whether in a bubble
whether it's harder to get funding you
know that soon what you know whatever I
don't think it's gonna change the mice I
don't think people are now gonna go back
and say you know what man
I really want to just have a job and
work for the man it's not like how it
with people like you and me out there
saying chase your dreams like it's not
gonna happen right
it will get harder there are harsh
realities of being an entrepreneur but
you know most companies don't get funded
by angel investors in VC so that that
investment bubble might burst but it
doesn't impact 99% of entrepreneurs and
I think as people see more different
types of entrepreneurs breaking through
they're gonna want to do the same and be
inspired what's the story I remember
Whoopi Goldberg Whoopi Goldberg was
watching when she was a young girls
watching star
track the first Star Trek with Captain
Kirk in lieutenant O'Hara O'Hara forget
forgetting was pants I'm not a big
Trekkie
but she was one of the first black woman
on TV yeah
and Whoopi said mommy mommy there's a
black woman on TV and she's not hurt
she's not a maid servant right like she
was third in command or whatever of the
of the of the ship and so like that
inspired her to want to become an
actress you know people are gonna listen
to your show and say man Daniels rocking
it I want to do that like that's my
dream and you're starting they're gonna
start off with like eight years old
going off and doing interviews man like
that's crazy isn't it crazy that there's
Miss Fortune your own Kindle podcast now
we're starting late in life bro six I'm
an old name like the next generation is
already coming you got one of the guys
in the chat Chiara is a fan of the
channel and part of the team sent me
this article both this nine year old
millionaire you know yeah yeah we've got
a steer on our facility so I don't think
it's going anywhere man I think it's
only gonna get I think I see it as good
I see it as better I like seeing people
living their dreams man I hate I hate
the idea of people being stuck in a box
that they hate and feeling like that's
all there is to life yeah I mean we were
part of it I mean I was at the very tail
end of this probably people who are my
age or younger or the only ones who are
now or older or all that once we were
gonna remember life without the internet
I mean because everything after that you
know I remember when you know we had
computers but they just ran awful slow
floppy disks you know and and and now
the things that we can do I mean talk
about the most overloads
taken-for-granted device ever you know
it's pretty incredible where we're
headed and it's easy to take this stuff
for granted one thing that I find helps
me with kind of putting everything into
perspective is I've stopped automating a
lot of stuff I'm curious to know about
your workflow this will probably help me
and my this is gonna be a selfish
question
because I'm building my youtube channel
as well we switched from from the ridge
20 YouTube channel to a personal graphic
I think it's overall gonna be a better
play but we kinda started at zero again
I was only at maybe like 4,000 when I
switched so it wasn't that big with you
know so I'm starting to build it back up
again doing all the normal stuff like
you know posting every doing videos
every day mostly to the email list if
we're not selling something
I know social media all that stuff and
and so I guess for a new youtube or
someone who and this is especially
doesn't have an audience cuz we're gonna
look at me say well yeah but you'll just
take them on your quarter million
followers on Instagram and direct them
so it's easy for you alright take me out
of the equation for someone was just
starting and they have a great message
to share is just being prolific enough
are there like I know there are no real
hacks but like what are some things that
maybe a beginner would overlook in the
video game it's you don't want to get
the answer I know the like people that
want to hear the answer it's just work
like making them bigger videos I know
this is what happens to me jus doesn't
happen to me every quarter like man I
feel like I'm crushing it like the
quality is really good
finally spired by the stuff you know I
get all energized or crying or whatever
like I get emotional watch my videos
videos my videos move me
I'm the filter and I feel like man these
are good things they should be out more
I feel like I am adding so much to
humanity with this channel yeah that
like more people need to see it
mm-hmm and then I think okay great that
frustration leads to action as a natural
entrepreneur okay I need to market
better I need to do work with
influencers I need to tweet these things
out more I need to build up a group
that's out hustling for me I need to do
more collaborations right like the
marketing plan and then at the end of
the day the thing that matters most that
moves the needle is just better videos
like the videos need to be better right
like you need to be a better interviewer
I need to be a better interview
we I need to have a better lens I need
to do better editing like it's just
better stuff and my channel you know
might have exploded in the past year and
a half or whatever why because the
videos got better right we're growing
faster now because the videos have
gotten even better and so if I was a new
youtuber most of my growth even now
comes off of youtube like not from me
promoting that anywhere else
native on YouTube and so if I was a new
youtuber getting started up I would make
it spray on your time but I would I
would look at a video a day and just
focus on getting better every single day
and that's a sucky answer I hate it I
know it's so not fun because what you've
done is you've given you've given it
given directions without a real map you
know and it's so hard but you know it is
it's like the it's the only is the only
thing that really works anymore cuz
hacks always get tired and then we stop
working and they never really like lead
to long-term success you know but the
consistency over time is the only thing
that really seems to work it just sucks
yeah yeah that's why you gotta enjoy the
work man
I mean it's it sucks it there's no quick
thing but it's also relief that you know
what like I just don't keep doing my
thing I think I keep getting better it's
got to keep pushing it well also you
never really doesn't think too
especially with viral pieces my my
experience going viral has mostly been
in the written well so like it but if I
get syndicated by me out Leonard you
know I have an article go viral or
whatever and people will say oh man like
how did you crack the viral article I
would say I can't think of one article
that I wrote that I thought was gonna go
viral go viral and know all the ones I
didn't think would go I don't think
would happen work ended up working out I
was talking up a friend Mark Manson
about this Susan even better you know or
more well-known writer than me I should
say and he said the same thing and the
interesting thing is that a lot of times
for me the pieces that have spreading
the most or having the most reach you
know the ones that make you grow
overnight are ones that I've either been
scared publishers like oh this could
piss some people off of this would be
this could be this could be a heaven
response or ones that were complete
sleepers
I just really wanted to or feel so like
I had one video since we switched
channels it's lost all its views but
it's still going live on Facebook and
it's one video is about Tupac and it's
about like the value of urgency
consistency in this clip of him where
he's like he's like you know we got to
do three songs a day like we don't have
time for you to be sleeping in the
studio or like making beats while I'm in
here rapping and we're you know get the
track bring it over here make it let's
do it like you know in its period of
time before he died he'd be like you
know twelve albums he started beat
movies he wrote two books all this
production so this were talking about
and I'm just going off on this thing and
I put up a Facebook and it gets 1.5
million views I'm like okay you know
there's no formula for that but the next
week back at it Bruce more videos next
video hundred views so there's not
really a lot of laws but there are rules
and that one of them is consistency
yeah if you can addicted to the views
like that that hundred view video as
long as you're proud of it like I want
to make videos that I want to show my
son and my grandkids that's what I want
to make right you want to make better
videos like you want to bust on your
YouTube channel make a video that when
somebody sees it they want to share it
because it moved them so much that's it
okay with this here's here's simple
example don't like moving something okay
so that's like that's digging down into
getting into the real stuff that that
makes you you and really you need to
that's why you create every day so you
can find that place inside of you that's
real and you can write about or shooter
or talk about real stuff like what's
something that a lot of beginning
youtubers overlook and putting together
their content because a lot of us try to
copy what else is working should we try
to copy accepted formats like you have a
great format should someone try to copy
your style or should they try to figure
out their own stuff should they reinvent
the wheel or try to model cuz people are
big on modeling to 20 elements a model
success I'll you will say to Bob say go
to your own thing well sir I'd answer
the answer is both ah kill him yeah yeah
like and here let me go deeper with it
like there's a ton of people who are
copying my stuff like you do the exact
same formula
some people just caught they just rip
the videos exactly as they are like we
are
feature like you know now we have like
10 clip there a couple clips at the
beginning we say coming up or coming
soon or whatever and you know the
copycats do the same thing coming soon
kind of like different fonts or whatever
doesn't bother me like you cannot out
Evan Evan I've been like I will always
be a step ahead because you have no
ingenuity so I don't I don't worry about
it
and people send me stuff all the time
like ever these guys keep you guys up if
I focus my time on beating those guys
instead of doing something new when I'm
pissed like that's not a good way I want
to spend my day and nothing innovative
is coming up on my channel and so I
think that the answer that the the real
answer is you need to do your own thing
but to get there you need to model just
like the quantity leads to the quality
right like you don't know what you're
doing at the start the reason why nobody
watches your videos is because you suck
and then fine like you suck at the start
of everything right like I'm sure Daniel
your first interview socks compared to
where you right now compared to where
you're gonna be in three years right the
more you do right you can get the Larry
King level or better than Larry King or
whatever whatever your ambition is when
somebody's starting off on YouTube they
suck and that's fine most people
actually quit there because they
realized they suck
yeah and they they have these
expectations of being great and they
know they can't do that yet and they
just quit they give up too soon they
make free videos on their own expect a
suck model model success I'm a big fan
but everything I've modeled from
somebody else and I'd model all these
guys everything I've modeled has never
worked exactly like they did it yeah I
have to learn something and then apply
it and make it work for me and a great
example I work with a media coach for a
while for my youtube channel how to get
better at speaking all that and she
would always give me these exercises and
I hated them to stretch me I hated them
and they never worked like what she
wanted me to do never worked as she
thought it would work but I always then
took what she said and twisted it to
make it work for me eventually it was
painful but her advice with my own
little sweet sauce to it made it work
and so it's both it's take what these
guys are saying it's
hey you're not gonna be Lilly Singh
don't try to do really thing right
don't try to be the next day on the yeah
you gotta be you but you can learn from
Lilly Singh you learn for me you learn
from Daniel to find pieces that's all I
do is I learn from all of these people I
don't want to be the next Steve Jobs I
want to be the best me and I'm learning
from all these guys and taking pieces to
help me be that best mate and so maybe
Steve is a terrible manager right like
how to treat people as a human being
maybe he's not the greatest at that
awesome I have my parents for that I
have other people that I learned from
that right thinking big what I have a
huge impact
awesome right like that's what I pull
from him injected into me a little shot
of jobs and I suck right and so it if
you just go off and try to do your own
thing could work but having some kind of
blueprint roadmap will help you but if
all you do is stick to that then you're
never gonna get to where you could be so
it's both it's the quantity leads to the
quality it's the model success to then
become your own person it's both yeah I
totally agree with you and I think it's
worth kind of like as comfortable worth
using that point to crystallize this
whole interview I think about I think
about originality I think about how
you've created original content out of
unoriginal content because all the stuff
that you've created you know as is
anything on the internet you could look
that up
but it's not about necessarily having
information pairs about something the
information in a way that you can
receive it especially if in someone that
that you know a viewer hasn't been
introduced to before you know you're
much more willing to watch an engaging
video that's well produced has good
graphics also has had research time and
development put into to extract the most
interesting parts and that's where
that's the part that people should be
modeling the idea of extracting good
stuff
not necessarily Evans model of
extracting good stuff that's just your
thing I I learned this this was actually
a fairly recent realization you know for
a few years I was struggling in
kind of like online personality space
because I saw what was working I am very
good at making sales I could market I
have courses so they sell and I make
money that's great
I was always feeling a little bit hollow
like I wasn't really able to find a way
that made me different from everyone
else because I mean at the end of the
day I'm teaching people how to make
money I see people I make money from
freelancing that's that you want to make
money from all my business that's great
but like that message isn't new and the
mediums I'm using to express that
messages to do so I kind of think what's
my original thing and just like you said
no one can out em and edit no one can
now Daniel Daniel so I started doing
things that just were uncopyable I
started talking about really difficult
experiences like my grandmother just
passing away and how it just [ __ ]
crushed me I started bringing my dad I
just put up I just put up a video on our
Channel just this morning about my dad
and I having a conversation that I
recorded and it's not all family stuff
some of it's just other stuff that's so
specific to my life that you couldn't
copy it in a marketing context to make
it look like really there would be no
context for you to copy what I just said
because only me I can put that up there
right so if you're having trouble if
you're watching this and you're watching
Evans work and you're like man I'm never
gonna have a channel 460,000 subscribers
like em and it's too complicated or like
you know I'm never gonna get a blue
checkmark at social media like Daniel
that's too legit like don't worry about
that [ __ ] there's nothing that you're
gonna be able to do to be who we are and
this is gonna sound super corny so
prepare yourself but she's gotta be you
gotta be yo you and to understand who
that is it creates it requires you to to
produce a lot of work and so I encourage
you guys to check out a master who's
really done this at a level that I
aspire to you told me you're doing six
videos a day now I mean this might be a
special day for you and you don't do
that much right Lily is that true out of
Thursday's I might interview video days
so we're at 7 today but a usual day
would be 5 5 to 6 a day I'm not I'm
doing I'm doing I'm writing an article
and a video a day and that's about all I
can do right now but all but I have a
team to write like it's not it's me and
my team right yeah yeah my team is right
John
email the marketing efforts out to get
it to hire more people but certainly you
are your model in productivity
creativity and not only just inspiration
but real special ideas that have been
around for a long time so I wanted to
thank you for taking your time sue to
have a meaningful conversation with the
same cool men will happy to be on the
show it's been it's been a blast and and
really excited for your journey to grow
if I could just throw that in there
because I've done a lot of interviews
and you you've got you've got the raw
energy and genuine curiosity that I
think like continuing on this path and
just continue to Tupac style grind it
out you'll you'll do really special
things I'm not just I'm not just filling
your head man I mean it appreciate you
man well you know what I'll do
I drop on a mixtape soon and it's it's
like a little bit Evan Carmichael
inspired it has people who have inspired
me with interesting words plus my ideas
mixed in I'm not rapping don't worry but
I did a rap on my channel
yeah I did a Mother's Day rap I did a
version of the twenty one pilots dress
down on it for my mom on Mother's Day so
what role rap do it I had dude mix I
have a lot of black pressure on me if I
rap it has to be good okay maybe 100 200
final copy so I'll make sure to send you
a copy some dope it cool let me let me
just say to this is important xeno in
the chat this guy's been on all seven
hangouts today he's one of my most
hardcore fans he just wrote this was
great certainly one of my favorite
interviews on your channel Evan yeah all
right man we'll expose it cool well
thank you guys so much for watching on
my side have an amazing night I'm done
for the day
continue to believe whatever your one
where it is no see you soon